Let's say we want to continue formalizing
our HTML grammar in Python.
One of the other types of elements in HTML,
aside from bare words, is
tag-decorated words.
You might put <bold> or an <anchor>
or even something more complicated, like this, that changes the color.
So just to remind you of what these HTML tags look like,
they start with this Left Angle, there's some name;
they might have some arguments, there's a Right Angle;
there can be any HTML in the middle;
then there's this Left Angle Slash, another word, and a Right Angle.
And here, I've just written out that grammar rule:
this LANGLE corresponds to this part.
this word goes here,
tag arguments--color = "Red",
Right Angle is that one, HTML is here,
LANGLESLASH is these two, and so on.
And, here, I'll build up my parse tree
by using part[2]: zero, 1, 2,
the word, like span or bold or underline;
the tag arguments--if there are any,
the body--the words that are being modified by bold or underline,
and then, finally, the final word--
just to make sure, later on, that you've opened <span>
and closed </span> or opened <bold> and closed </bold>.
Remember, we want those parentheses to match.
And our input text is: hello <baba> yaga,
and we've got <baba> bolded.
I'm going to ask you to take apart this concept and do it backwards.
I have written out the parse tree,
down here at the bottom,
but I've left 3 blanks.
I would like you to fill in the blanks
with a single word
that will make this parse tree correspond to
what our parser will produce on this input.